answer I you say in your bio that you
help to rebrand your family liquor store
to wine library and then you sort social
media to spread the word about the wine
library and that helped grow the company
from four million dollars in sales to
sixty million in about five years um is
that like a direct correlation there or
there's a lot no so I think this story
gets muddled a lot great that I could
tell it was a little muddled that's why
I wanted to ask you about it yeah and
I've said this a whole bunch of times I
mean it's I'm not sure where that like I
think I found it online online versus my
website is a whole different thing I
think you know I'm not sure where you
got it from but I know that this is a
story that gets muddled great because I
launched winelibrary.com in 1996 and why
not be TV started in 2006 yeah the
business had already grown to 40 40 it's
why you see 45 and 60 and I don't know
if this is right opportunity like
cleared up yeah I would say the calm and
the what was social media back then
which was ecommerce SEO SEM and can't
you know that kind of marketing right
wine searcher calm traditional media
okay that was the initial boost and then
what was really most exciting was when I
went to content marketing I was able to
continue to grow the business for that
45 - I come next year without spending
anywhere close to the amount of money so
it first started through you listen the
first year up to three you know if you
want to really connect the dots the
first three years call it 96 call it 98
99 call it 96 97 98 99 that was done
through operations that was me on the
floor selling more then the website
kicked in the momentum in 2000 2001 2002
then search marketing 2002 2003 2004
then then kind of like just fixing and
getting better at it oh four oh five and
then oh six started Wine Library TV
which took it to the next place and the
reason it gets so much credit even by me
is I went from spending millions of
dollars right yeah to spending no money
right and using these new tactics which
is why I knew they would work for big
brain
because I'm like wait a minute if I
could save money on commercials print
full-page ads in the New York Times Wall
Street Journal so that but very often it
gets misquoted that like social media
yes so she didn't exist when I launched
Wine Library yes you know calm a couple
of times I've given presentations about
social media and I've used your your
case study as an example and I've been
trying to clarify the fafsa
clarification so i wanted to ask you
about it I could I wasn't clear it
groups sales to another base level and
more importantly in cut massive costs
yes so became a double win there was a
P&L victory right profit loss it was a
other time was being spent very much on
that 100% yeah yeah but I really think
especially for entrepreneurs yeah most
of us have time yeah most of us lack the
dollars upfront right sure